hello and welcome to the new world
review where we
are chickens not ants but chickens what
do i mean by chickens i'm glad you asked
me
we are chickens for we are afraid to act
in the way that is necessary to be able
to get to where we want or need to be
how do we stop being chickens
we fight kids when they're already
exhausted that's how we do it let's get
into it
shoot yeah shoot okay i kind of feel for
him the language the narrator used then
the subtitling was so
simple he's a coward i felt for him
immediately maybe he should just give up
how does a coward become a hunter and
this is one of those things actually
this is one of those things that i get
frustrated about with hunter hunter
because it's really hard to believe that
someone who is a coward would be able to
go into the hunter exam
and come out a hunter given the
competition that can happen for him to
have made it through the exam
everyone else would have had to be awful
and it's already been stated somewhere
or in my head i don't know i might have
made it up i'd do that sometimes
that some years no one passed and if
that's the case
how did he pass what did he do that made
him worthy of that license
what does his nen do and how did he
navigate all the issues that come with
being an example of such a broken
broken group of people i suppose just
being broken is kind of the point maybe
he becomes explosively angry and hulks
out but until i've seen him do this
thing i consistently struggle with thee
but how did this person get this far
issue that comes up every episode or two
leaving behind my sweaty sad coward boy
who i feel more protective over than i
thought i might gone is of course making
friends with
what's-her-face with the purple aura and
their desperation to kill people to go
to her love and save you that other guy
on the mountainside something i am
enjoying with her
i don't have a name for her it's okay
for now despite the two-dimensional
nature of her
and my lack of understanding about
exactly why she wants to kill them if
they fail when she could take the pieces
she needs and go
deal with the problem herself it just
seems anyway
despite that what i love about her is
her colour scheme
up to now we've seen purple used to
denote internally driven thoughts and
feelings
we've seen it used to halt action and to
show that the characters have an
internal world
well in this character here and i'm
going to call a single
because yeah single is singling out her
thoughts and making the internal
external enough that others can read it
resulting in the aura that's troubling
biski
despite the fact that she has no real
desire to kill bisky her perception
and her speech even her eyes are that
purple and since the eyes are the window
to the soul we could suggest that
metaphorically
the others can see her thoughts through
her eyes too and i love that because i
love a metaphor me
she reminds me very very heavily of
salad fingers and i wouldn't be
surprised to find that there was an
element of inspiration one way or the
other the similarities down to the
interaction with a knife
are remarkable her relationship with
gone is growing the way salad fingers
relationships grew too but with more
grotesque romantic comedy who doesn't
want to see single having difficulty
killing them because of a pinky promise
from possibly the only person to touch
her since who knows when
that each of the guys on site [ __ ]
mcsuit head and teeny glass
teeny glassy boy teeny teeny glassy
biggie nosy i don't know
like that guy have these specific
oddballs as their students it's great
because
they're actually pretty damn normal and
that normality and their boredom even is
needed to balance up the extremity of
the situation gone and kilowatt
are facing the things i noticed in this
episode were less emotional and a lot
more technical
another of those technical loves was the
art style change between when the ants
were in the forest to the simulated
world and
how that transition happened the puff of
smoke was a
delight to the eyes both the art and the
animation of the concept were delightful
and the fact that the appearance of the
portal on the other side was so
geometric
so clean cut there is a very clear
distinction to the environment and i am
a huge huge fan of artists shifting art
styles to portray experiential and
emotional changes it's one of the
reasons people love anime right there's
so much that can happen in held frames
that the specific length of a held frame
without any change can invoke as much
emotion
as detailing an animation but keeping
the models breathing throughout
meanwhile we have a brick [ __ ] house of
an ant appear given the softness of
all the other two wait menthol p is
really necessary for stereotype reasons
i don't really have an opinion on him
yet but i do have a lot of interest in
the puppeteering occurring on kite i
believe it was
it's showing the need to practice with
him before they go out and try to use
him in public and that's both horrific
in the sense that they're using
his body as a play thing but expected
because how else are you going to
get the outcomes you want meanwhile
meanwhile we have the king who is not
yet ready but all his guards have
appeared his hat is still solidly on his
head i checked
whether it will grow further we don't
know but he's growing and i'm hoping we
don't have a queen
ant he climax when he does appear given
how long it's taking the ark to
establish
it's looking like this one might be the
longest though i also have time
blindness and so maybe i'm
totally underestimating the amount of
time the previous arcs took to develop
and play out
either way i want to know more so let's
get into episode 89 where gone has found
out he has some weaknesses to his
simple answer to the simple question of
how to fight
everyone he comes across because like
his simple answer is just punch him
in it so gone now has a name for his
attack which i really truly did think
was
just called scissors paper rock because
he said it every time like i thought
that was how it worked
and now he has an even sillier name but
it works perfectly for him with this
episode we dug
further into kilwa's insecurities and
inner thoughts and now i'm wondering
whether we don't often go into god's
thoughts because he lives so much in the
present and without being
concerned about what might happen as a
consequence
of his behavior there's no point to us
hearing what's in his head because he
says what he's thinking soon enough
meanwhile kilwa is constantly preparing
to be gone's medic
or ambulance and get him out of
situations that he might be stuck in
he's very protective of gone but is that
going to be enough given the effect of
trauma that's been all he knows for so
long and i'm not
sure i know that some of that is biased
some of my knowledge of this is bias
because i've been mildly spoiled on the
fact that kilauea will
leave at some point but i have no idea
when that is or why
this seems like a really strong
potential though if it's what happens
i'm not sure how i'll take it to be
honest
what is fascinating is the suggested
similarities between
gone and knuckle and shoot and keelwa
right down to their colour palettes
we have two deeply thoughtful characters
who act like edgelords despite being
very afraid of everything that comes
their way meanwhile we have two
extroverted punchy people who are about
living in the moment and enjoying what
they can while they can
while gone isn't at all a pacifist he
has and still is yet to
actually get a full focused kill yes
he squished a bug in panic but the fact
that he's now making it clear that he's
unwilling to hold back
is really critical because it means he's
willing to kill
in cold blood his use of knuckles
weakness in that moment
also can't be understated he knew he
couldn't win that fight against knuckle
he told us so what he also knew was that
knuckle is a big softy who wouldn't
actually kill him if he tried his
careless
attack attempt and that kilwa would help
him essentially he was counting on the
weakness of those around him to
compensate for his lack of ability
that said if he'd managed to pull off
the attack on knuckle it would have been
part of the job and he'd have moved on
because that's kind of how it's supposed
to work
the outward softness is knuckles major
downfall while gone's failure to predict
kilwa's constant anxiety about
situations is going to potentially be
his meanwhile kilwa has biscuit secret
and can't share it under pain of face
breakage but also
it seems biscuit didn't even need to
attack him with her fist she got him in
the heart
what must it feel like for kilwan
knowing deep down that he would do what
he needs to do to save himself because
that's what his family wants rather than
trying
ultimately to save the boy he loves he
may not even be cognizant of it any
awareness he has
of what his brother did to him is sort
of melted into fear and when we get
highly anxious stressed or triggered we
can
fail to make or encode memories memories
have to go through the making phase you
have to experience something
and then you have to go through a
process that stores the memory for later
that's a little over simplistic but it's
why if a kid's throwing a tantrum
you wait until they're done not because
they can't hear you while they're
screaming but because they're so
emotional they won't remember what
you're saying when they have calmed down
when kilwa goes into assassin mode does
he remember what's happening or is it
activating a sleeper situation
each time he's killed it's largely been
a response to heightened emotions
or life or death he's shown he has some
control over it but i think it's less
controlled than
we've been led to believe to now i keep
going back to the first time he killed
someone with his strange spare hand
situation and it was such an immediate
lashing out of emotion that i don't
wonder if he remembers it but whether he
has control over it whether it's a
consequence of raised emotion
that's a deep dive into the psychology
of trauma but with kilowatt it tends to
be quite necessary
especially since we're about to see the
two cowards face off now cowardice is a
fear response so i do wonder
what it is that shoots most afraid of
the fact that they
exist the fact that he has to fight them
or the response from his teacher if he
fails or
something else entirely if we assume
keel was afraid of not being worthy of
gone it makes his goal very simple and
if we assume
kilau is more afraid of dying because
the curse says he must live
his bond with gon becomes secondary
though it's still distressing and maybe
more distressing because he doesn't have
a choice
of what happens i think what biski's
done giving him an ultimatum like this
is to push kilwa to the brink of
friendship the brink of
family testing his values and testing
his willingness and ability to grow
it's like we've gone all the way back to
the end of the first art why hasn't
kilwa fought for an entire month what is
he hiding from
every step along the way i've sort of
assumed because he would show aspects of
competence that he was growing with gone
now it's not that he's not capable but
if he's questioning that capability
she's right he's lost before he's begun
that he's not telling gone about it
suggest that he genuinely doesn't have
an answer either
i wonder whether has any doubts about
gon's friendship
is a friend really your friend if
they're willing to hurt you or get you
into such dangerous situations
when is enough enough i used to think
gone was a parallel for cult but it's
killah isn't it gone is the instinctive
ant the ant who does
what he must because the environment
says he must
kilwa he considers the emotionality of
it he considers others he considers gone
having seen kite lose his arm trying to
protect them
and in fact kite has a similar colour
scheme tequila
the same propensity to hide his eyes the
same ability to kill at a moment's
notice because that is what is expected
rather than what is wanted and both are
puppets at the end of the day gone's
fight with knuckle wasn't important
because of gone's process
it was important because kilwa was
watching kilwa was the focus of this
episode kilwa was the one judging
whether it would be necessary to step
in if knuckle had tried to kill gon
while he was down kilwa would have
stepped in i believe that
as it was his eyes hardened a sign of
big emotion
or emotional blunting um we would call
it from
that kid and emotional blunting while
that self-serving smothering love came
into play he picked him up
child style and took him home put him in
bed the zoldick family for all their
awful behaviors toward each other
are an abusively loving family which
doesn't make much sense but
kind of does and keel was taking those
traits and placing them on gone
knocking him out and smothering him in
protection he hasn't actually asked for
it seems that abusive relationship works
both ways
that was a lot sorry that was a lot of
psychology
i'm looking forward to seeing how this
plays out but for now
that is it from me you can also click
here here and here for other stuff
i will try to be less cerebral next time
and then i'll see you
that's right i'll see you next time